This is a Minuteman 3 Missile, capable of
carrying up to three thermonuclear warheads.
They range from 3-5 hundred kilotons.
That’s more powerful than 6 hundred million
pounds of dynamite.
And this is a cutting edge computer from the
early 1990s.
And is used as the system processor to launch
the Minuteman 3 Intercontinental ballistic
missiles.This is how we would conduct nuclear
war, on eight inch floppy disks.
This is an 8 inch floppy disk.
It holds just under 250 kilobytes.
It’s only good for text documents, a super
low-res photo or a song.
Right now there are over 450 Minuteman three
missiles buried deep under fields in the sparsely
inhabited regions of the United States.
They are connected by a spider-web of thousands
of miles of cables, ready to strike at top
secret targets faster than you can get a pizza.
Welcome to F.E. Warren Air Force Base, home
of the 90th Missile Wing.
They command 150 of these Minuteman III missiles.
It's hard to imagine a weapons system more
powerful than the one we operate.
And yet, these missiles, their launch control
centers and their command capsules all operate
on this antiqued technology.
That processor that it uses to basically run
the operating system, is about a 386 equivalent,
so you are looking at early 90s technology.
There is a cursor, it’s a square.
Like an old Atari 2600.
We use a trackball not a mouse.
It has 100 megabytes of hard drive memory
and it has about 16 megabyte of ram.
The missiles itself, that guidance computer,
uses an operating system about the size of
an 8 inch floppy disk.
It’s about 200 kilobytes of memory and one
channel of communication uses that floppy
disk to tell the system how to operate.
It was cutting edge technology back in 1971.
Old technology is not necessarily bad thing.
With an older weapons system like the Minuteman
3, which really was designed in the late 60s
early 70s, if it still works, and it provides
us some good benefits, let’s leave it in
place and not mess with it.
There are benefits to old technology.
Modern networked computers can be easily hacked
and compromised with malware, and with these
machines, that’s more difficult.
We don't use modern technologies such as I
say wifi, WiFi’s been around for decades,
Wifi, Bluetooth.. there's no cloud for the
Minuteman III operating weapons system, we
don’t use those technologies and that gives
us a certain amount of security because it
reduces the number of vulnerabilities we have.
To say anything is hackerproof, absolutely,
100% is, that’s dangerous and we would never
say that we are 100% hacker proof.
We take a great amount of effort to ensure
that we are mitigating every potential vulnerability
that we can identify.
While these computers may be from the 70s,
the missileers who run these facilities, skew
a bit younger.
Most of them are too young to remember the
Floppy Disk, not to mention Pac Man or Pong.
In fact the disks they're handling are (in
some cases) older than they are.
The missileers look for false alarms and fake
intruder signals caused by stray deer and
bad weather.
The combination of old technology and humans
is what has kept the Minuteman 3 safe so far.
Look, they're old, and we know that, but a
lot of the obscure technology that we use
still works.
So if we don’t need to upgrade it, then
we don’t.
With the Minuteman weapons system, because
it is so important and so vital, and the destructive
power of the weapon’s system is so vast.
Above and beyond anything else we need to
ensure that this weapons system is safe and
secure.
And I can tell you right off the bat, I have
complete confidence in the safety and security
of our weapons system and the nuclear weapons
that we use on the nuclear weapons system.
So although these machines might be antiquated,
this is still arguably one of the most powerfully
impactful computer systems in human history…
So, any changes they're going to make will
have to be really well thought out, and top,
top secret.
For more science documentaries, check out
this one right here!
Don’t forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.